Speaker 1: After a right wing, anti-Semitic,
anti-vax. Q And on Trump is not
broke into Nancy Pelosi's House and hit
her husband over the head with a hammer.
Fox News anchor Jesse WATTERS said, Listen,
a lot of people get hit with hammers.
And if they hadn't defunded the police
in San Francisco, which didn't happen,
maybe this wouldn't have taken place.
It's unbelievable. But this is what
they're going with. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: What I want is that I want this alleged
perpetrator to be treated the exact same way if
he had treated if he had attacked anybody else,
because a lot of people get hit with hammers,
why a lot of people get attacked and a lot of
the times they're out on bail the next day.
And it's a simple assault charge. So I don't
know why this guy is being treated differently
and he's facing, what, attempted homicide. He's
in prison right now. We've seen people assault
people all the time randomly with all kinds of
weapons. And we see them released the next day.
Speaker 1: It's not not super tough on crime when
it's Trumpist rioters on January six or a middle
of the night home invasion. These are the types of
home invasions that the right loves to say. This
is when you just shoot them with your self-defense
gun. They love talking about home invasions. And
yet now he's like, Well, the guy's actually being
treated potentially too harshly, too harshly.
Usually you say these people can be shot.
Speaker 2: But don't know why this guy is
getting all of a sudden special treatment or
different treatment because the victim was so high
profile. Remember, if you call on a welfare check,
the left wants to send a social worker. What
if a social worker had come to this call?
You would had a dead husband and you
would have had a dead social worker? Yeah.
Speaker 1: I have not seen, nor have I suggested,
that social workers be sent out to the middle of
the night home invasions where they're targeted
attacks. I have never said that. I've not heard
people on the left side that say that. I have
heard, hey, you know, if you have a homeless
person where police are called because they're
sleeping on a business stoop, maybe then you send
a social worker, maybe if you have, you know,
some kind of minor drug situation. But anyway,
they have to they have no choice but to put up
these straw men in order to tear them down. Now
you have to hand it to them. On the one hand, they
spent a week when the Fox News Christmas tree was
vandalized. No victims, no individual victims, and
a week they spent on that. And now it's listen,
a lot of people get hit with hammers. A
lot of people get hit with hammers. It
is truly unbelievable. And then also saying
this is because of the defunding of police,
there has been almost no defunding of police
anywhere in the country. And the police department
budget in San Francisco is up more than 4% since
2019. Waters and others love to say they've
defunded the police. That's why this is happening.
But they've not defunded the police and it has
nothing to do with it. It actually the Hammers
thing reminds me of the good liars. Remember
our friends, the good liars went to the NRA
convention and this this guy, they talk to you try
to talk about hammers and it went south very.
Speaker 2: Quickly for people and more crime is
committed and more people are killed with
hammers every year than guns. Look at the
facts. I will look that up. I don't think that's
true. Actually, it's true in the United States,
though, sir. That is true. Look it up. It's on.
You can Google it. It's true. It's actually true.
So the number of murder victims and
the weapons used. Okay, number one,
handguns, 8029. Number two, firearms type, not
stated. 4863. Number three, knives or cutting
instruments, personal weapons, fists, feet,
then rifles at 455 and blunt objects, clubs,
hammers, 393. The 300, the hammers that that stat
is just wrong. To your question, Second Amendment
is still my right and it's still important to me.
Speaker 1: Everything I said was wrong about the
hammers, but I still want my guns. And then one
more clip here. Check out how Fox News covers
the attack. And manages to completely omit the
entire political back story of the individual,
the fact that he's a MAGA nut, Cunanan,
anti-Semite, carnage, loving murder.
Speaker 3: Now, police have not stated a motive
for this attack. The suspect in this case,
the perp is reportedly from the Bay Area from
Berkeley. Fox Digital reports that this suspect
has ties to a radical nudist activist and has
a disturbing online presence that involves.
Speaker 1: The online presence, is disturbing.
Speaker 3: Posts about pedophiles, big brother
censorship and anti-Semitic content. And lawmakers
on both sides of the aisle swiftly condemned this
attack on Pelosi yesterday. Former Vice President
Mike Pence says this suspect should be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, what a completely anodyne
way to state. Listen, this is a radical
and everybody condemned it. So cold on
a second. The right wingers generically
condemn it while completely ignoring the
basis politically for what this guy did and
what his beliefs were. And it is, of course,
deliberate that they are doing that. So not an
altogether shocking response from the right.
Let's go to one more little chapter on this
related to the new Twitter owner, Elon Musk.